[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So you are here to hear
about the Innocence Project.
Today, we have with us
co-founder Barry Scheck,
who will also be introducing a
very special guest of his own.
Please help me
welcome Barry Scheck.
[APPLAUSE]
BARRY SCHECK: Thank
you very much.
It's a real privilege
and pleasure to be here.
And what we hope to do in the
short time we have with you,
and we will certainly be
taking your questions,
is give you a brief introduction
to the Innocence Project
and the Innocence Network.
That's a series of
organizations that do this work.
But the best ambassadors,
the best advocates,
the people that really
share with the country,
with legislators,
with decision makers,
with judges, with prosecutors,
with defense lawyers,
with everyone what
this work is all about
are our clients, the exonerated.
And so we are really
privileged today
to have here Kevin Richardson,
one of the defendants
in the Central Park Five case.
Come on up, Kevin.
[APPLAUSE]
So what we thought we'd do
in unusual format for lawyers
like me-- and I apologize.
I know I'm here at Google.
And I apologize for
wearing a suit and tie,
but I had to go to
court in the morning,
otherwise I wouldn't have done
that out of respect for you.
OK.
So let's get to it right away.
This should work, right?
Here we go.
Went too many--
OK.
The mission of the
Innocence Project
is to free wrongly convicted
people through DNA testing
and reform the
system responsible
for their unjust imprisonment
anywhere in the world.
It's the old mission.
Martin Luther King said,
an injustice anywhere
is an injustice everywhere.
And we seek to establish as
an international human right
that in every legal system,
adversarial or inquisitional--
because in some
countries, many in Europe,
you have legal systems what
they call inquisitional,
meaning that judges essentially
do the investigation.
It's not the typical
adversary system we have here.
However, in every
one of these systems,
what we find-- innocent
people get convicted.
And the international human
right we'd like to establish
is that there should be
a viable process in place
to be able to rectify a case,
where an innocent person is
convicted.
Viable process--
Now, in 1989, we had the
first DNA exoneration
in the United States.
By 1992, my co-founder and
co-director, Peter Neufeld,
and I started the Innocence
Project as a clinical program
at the Benjamin N.
Cardozo School of Law,
which is just a few
blocks away from here.
By 2004, we had an
independent nonprofit entity.
But what's most important
is that over the years,
almost from the
outset, we had partners
at law schools and
public defenders offices
all across the country that
we call an Innocence Network.
And we have 69
organizations worldwide
in the Innocence Network,
56 in the United States.
And let me be the
first to tell you
that in the other organizations
within our network,
we use both DNA and non-DNA
evidence to prove people
are innocent.
And we do that too at the
Innocence Project-- use
non-DNA evidence.
Here, just very
briefly, the numbers.
There have been 351
post-conviction DNA
exonerations in 37 states,
20 people sentenced
to death since 1989.
And we start with 1989 as the
beginning of the innocence era,
because that's when we first
began upsetting expectations
of everyone in the legal
system that there were
a lot more innocent people
than anybody ever knew about
through the DNA testing.
And the reason that we
focus on the DNA testing--
and if you go to the
Innocence Project website,
you'll see these numbers
and broken down by race,
by states, every way
you can imagine--
is that nobody is arguing
with these 351 exonerations.
They are all actually innocent.
They didn't do it.
And it's interesting
to note that in 150
of these cases, the person
who really committed
the crime has been identified.
So no one argues this.
There is a website
that I want to urge
you to look at
called the National
Registry of Exonerations,
which our colleagues
and partners run.
It's now at University of Irvine
Law School, Michigan State,
University of Michigan.
And there, we are keeping
track of an instrumental
number-- the best the
legal system can do.
And that is cases where there is
new evidence of innocence that
leads to a conviction being
vacated, meaning thrown out,
and then the case is dismissed.
Or somebody, in a few instances,
not many go, back to trial
and they're acquitted.
Now, in these cases, that
is the best definition
that the legal system
can come to in deciding
when there has been a
mistake or actually innocent.
The people that run the registry
would be the first to tell you
that we can't say
that absolutely
every one of those people is
actually innocent in the way
that we can say it
in the DNA cases.
But the truth is that the vast
overwhelming majority of them
are innocent.
And what's good about the
registry is that we now
have, since 1989,
2,089 cases where we've
been able to demonstrate that
innocent people were convicted,
people were convicted, new
evidence of innocence cases
dismissed.
And we're not even
counting mass exonerations,
and there have been
plenty of those.
And it makes it easier
to look at the data
and make a deep dive into
an analysis of this problem
of innocent people
being convicted, which
is a whole field of
scholarship, and we're first
just getting into it.
So take a look at the registry.
It It's worth looking at.
Now, we know about the causes
of wrongful convictions--
eyewitness misidentification--
71% of the wrongful convictions
in our DNA cases.
Misapplication of forensic
science in 45% of them,
and in the Central Park Five
case, which as you'll hear,
was primarily a false
confession case,
we still had bad
forensic science.
There were hairs that were found
on the poor young woman known
as the Central Park Jogger.
And they tried to claim
that some of these hairs
came from the defendants,
looking at it microscopically
just under a microscope.
And we know that a lot of that
microscopic hair comparison
evidence is
notoriously unreliable.
We were then able to do DNA
testing many years later
on the shafts of those
hair, something called
mitochondrial DNA testing,
and able to demonstrate
that the hairs didn't come
from any of these defendants.
And indeed, the source of
the hairs, as you'll hear,
comes from the person who
really committed that crime.
So 45% misapplication
of forensic science,
a huge cause of
wrongful convictions.
False confessions in 28%
of the cases, but close to,
I think, half of the
homicides, something like that.
Incentivized informant, a huge
problem around this country.
That, by the way, is a
picture of Betty Anne Waters,
and that's her
brother Kenny Waters.
And it's a wonderful
movie you might
want to take a look at
called "Conviction," starring
Hilary Swank, Sam Rockwell,
directed by Tony Goldwyn.
Isn't he the President
of the United States,
last time I looked?
But it's worth looking at.
That's that case.
Inadequate representation--
we all know that's
a terrible cause of
wrongful convictions.
Prosecutorial misconduct, the
field that we focus on a lot.
That's Michael Morton in Texas.
And we, at the Innocence Project
and in the Innocence Network,
we're kind of the headquarters.
We have a network
support unit, but we
go around the country,
both lobbying in Congress
for legislation
and in every state.
So when we started
the Innocence Project,
there were no
states that gave you
a right to get
post-conviction DNA testing.
Now, all 50 states
have such a bill.
They can even be improved,
but at least all 50
states and in Congress and
the federal government,
we have such a bill.
In 31 states, we have efforts,
legislation that requires
the preservation of evidence.
So you can go back years later
and prove people are innocent.
Recording of
interrogations that we're
going to discuss a lot today,
this is a critical reform.
We're talking about beginning
to videotape an interrogation
from the time of
Miranda warnings,
not as in the Central Park Five
case, after they tuned people
up, as they used to say at
"NYPD Blue," interrogate
them for hours, and
then after it's all over
and all the coercion has taken
place and all the feeding
of facts, they come in and
they begin a videotape later.
That's not videotaping
of interrogation
in any meaningful way.
Eyewitness identification--
in 19 states,
we've been able to
seriously change
the different methods of doing
identification procedures,
whether it's photo
arrays or lineups,
to reduce the risk
of error and trying
to enhance the capability
of law enforcement
to get correct identifications.
Forensic science--
we're working on it.
There was just a--
we had a National Commission
on Forensic Science that
came about after the National
Academy of Science in 2009
issued a groundbreaking report.
But the National Commission
is a thing of the past.
After the election,
it was disbanded.
So we are still
working everywhere
to expand policy reforms.
We're focusing more on indigent
defense, on criminal courts,
and particularly what we
call America's guilty plea
problem, the issue of
innocent people pleading
guilty to crimes
they didn't commit.
That's one of our
earliest clients,
Chris Ochoa, who pled guilty
to a homicide in Texas
under literally being
threatened with,
if you don't confess
to this crime,
you're going to get executed.
We will needle you, is
precisely what they told Chris.
He confessed to a crime
that he didn't commit.
Now, he's graduated from the
University of Wisconsin Law
School and is a lawyer and works
hard in the innocence movement.
But we're really focusing on
innocent people pleading guilty
in the misdemeanor
courts, because one
of the major issues, as you all
know, I hope, is bail reform,
is making sure that people
are not kept in jail just
because they can't
afford bail, where
they wind up pleading guilty
to crimes they didn't commit.
And misdemeanors or what
they call low level felonies
has huge collateral consequences
for people everywhere.
But because we have Kevin
here, and he is so kind
to come and share his
experiences with us today,
let us talk about one of
the truly historic cases
in the modern history of
American jurisprudence--
it really is-- the
Central Park Jogger case.
And I'm looking
around the room, and I
think a lot-- how many
of you have heard of it?
Well, that's a lot.
I think it's probably true,
because of the wonderful movie
that Sarah Burns and Dave
McMahon, her husband,
made called the
"Central Park Five."
How many of you saw that movie?
Let the record reflect
a lot of the same people
raised their hands.
It's a terrific
movie and you all
should go see it
and get it online.
But this case started
in April of 1989
when a young woman who was an
investment banker, actually
a wonderful person whose
overcome horrible injuries,
was jogging in Central Park, as
was her habit and pattern, when
she was mugged.
That night in
Central Park, there
were other instances of people
being attacked and mugged
in the park.
They called it wilding,
as a slang term.
And they developed this
term of super predators.
But the jogger herself, as
she was called in those days,
was found, like, in a ditch,
horribly beaten, stabbed.
It's a miracle that she
lived through the experience.
And this is what the newspaper
headlines looked like.
But the long story
short, and I'll
tell just a short
version of the story,
the involvement of the
Innocence Project in this case
is, strangely enough, after
Kevin and his colleagues
were convicted in, I guess, two
trials, and all five of them
went to jail for
different periods of time,
and the city was convinced
that these young men,
these so-called super
predators, as they were called,
they saw their
confessions on television.
And nobody was showing
any remorse, right?
Which was a big deal.
And of course, they
weren't showing remorse,
because they were innocent.
They didn't do anything, right?
But years later, we at
the Innocence Project
got a letter from a
man named Matias Reyes.
And Matias Reyes wrote to
us and one other lawyer
in New York City
and said, you know
what, I'm the person that
committed that crime.
I'm the one that
attacked the jogger.
And of course, he was in
jail himself for murder.
What's really
extraordinary about this
is that a friend, a very
good lawyer, who was working
in the New York City
District Attorney's office,
named Harlan Levy
wrote a book called--
he was their DNA expert.
He wrote a book called
"And the Blood Cries Out."
And the first
chapter in the book
is about Matias Reyes
being convicted with DNA
evidence for a break-in murder.
And by the way, he always tried
to bash the eyes of his victims
so nobody could identify him.
And the jogger, of
course, her eyes
were in that state as
well-- broken sockets.
But the beginning
of the book is,
look at the power
of DNA evidence.
Then he has another
chapter in the book talking
about how he advised the
prosecutors Elizabeth Lederer
and Linda Fairstein and others
who prosecuted the Central Park
Five to ignore it to
get around the fact
that there was semen evidence
that didn't come back to any
of the defendants nor the
jogger's boyfriend that
was found on the vaginal swabs
and on the shorts, as I recall.
And that's part of the book.
And little did he know
that years later Matias
Reyes would come forward.
Matias Reyes said to
the Innocence Project,
I'm the person who really
committed the crime.
And this is really how--
one of the things
we want to discuss
and I want you to
really focus on
is, when you have these
media storms in a case
like this, those of you
that are New Yorkers--
I'm looking around the room--
ask your parents
what this was like.
And we're going to discuss
it in a second with Kevin.
Talk about the daily news.
There was wall to wall coverage.
Everybody was obsessed
with this case.
It came at a
terrible time, where
crime was spiking, where you
had an epidemic of narcotics
distribution in this city.
And people were scared.
And Reyes came forward
years, years later.
He said, I really
committed this crime.
And we then took this to the
New York County prosecutors.
And there were
two of them that I
want to single out
for praise, because I
want it clear that in the
criminal justice reform
movement that we hope is
really taking off now,
those who are progressive
prosecutors, who
are willing to admit mistakes
and reinvestigate fearlessly,
they must be praised.
And this never
would have happened
unless Peter Casolaro and Nancy
Ryan agreed to take this on.
There were a number of reporters
in the city that had heard
that something was cooking.
And all the lawyers
involved in the case
were able to keep this quiet for
seven months in New York City--
seven months-- while they
reinvestigated the case.
Now, I don't know.
I'm sure here at Google, you
will appreciate seven months
with an incendiary
story like this,
to keep that quiet
is a miracle, right?
But that was done.
And it gave Nancy and
Peter the opportunity,
along with their own
DA investigators,
to independently investigate
this, to go talk to Reyes.
They actually found
another case right
by that area in
Central Park where
Reyes, a day or two
before, had committed
another sexual assault,
a vicious one, that
was never prosecuted,
and partly because they
couldn't find anybody and
the victim of that case moved
to California.
But it was the same MO, the
same person, Matias Reyes.
And then, of course, by the time
that they were reinvestigating,
they'd known he'd gone
on to commit murders.
And they also, in
their re-investigation,
he didn't know any of the
five defendants, right?
And the way it wound
up is that they did
this massive reinvestigation.
They corroborated
everything Reyes said.
It was completely consistent
with the DNA evidence,
with the hair evidence,
with the forensic evidence
at the scene, everything,
and with the timeline.
Because the truth
is, the timeline
never made any sense in the
Central Park Jogger case.
And at the time, many
people pointed that out.
So they presented their case
to District Attorney Robert
Morgenthau.
By that time, word
had gotten out.
The police department
began reinvestigating.
And the prosecutors
in the case-- and they
made a huge presentation
to Mr. Morgenthau
saying, no, no, no, we
think they're still guilty.
We stand behind this.
And Morgenthau, to
his credit, they
filed a huge affidavit
in court detailing
the entire
investigation and agreed
to vacate the conviction.
And that is, if you're
interested historically,
is an important document
for you to take a look at.
So Matias Reyes pled
guilty to that crime.
Everybody knows
that he was-- well,
he didn't plead guilty because
the statute of limitations
had run.
But everybody agrees that
he is the person that
committed the crime, and the
convictions were vacated.
Very long story
short, it took years,
but there was massive civil
litigation in this case.
And the City of New York
and our corporation counsel
Zach Carter, who was a
US attorney in this city
and is a great great lawyer, all
agreed that these young men are
innocent, and they
settled a civil case
for many millions of dollars.
And that, believe me, wouldn't
have happened unless everybody
was completely-- in the city--
completely convinced and
the corporation counsel's
office that they were innocent.
There is still some
people that to this day--
I think it's an example of a
certain kind of cognitive bias
where you can't let go--
still insist that
they're guilty.
But any reasonable person, I
think, examining the evidence
can't reach that conclusion.
So what do we make of this, and
why is this case so important?
Well, one reason,
of course, has to do
with trying to get up
the number of states
that videotape interrogation
and actually look at the way
that people are interrogated
to make sure that we don't have
this problem of false
confessions, which
is incredibly difficult
and pernicious.
But how do you get that done?
I'll never forget
that just before--
and I was telling Kevin
this the other day--
just before we went to announce
in court that the Central Park
Five were going to have their
convictions vacated, somebody
from The New York
Civil Liberties Union
and myself went to one
of the deputy mayors
in the city of New York and
what was going on, and said,
this is the time to
videotape interrogations.
Let's make sure
there are no errors.
We'll see exactly what happens
from Miranda warnings forward.
And we said, use
this as the time.
And the truth is, because of
the real pushback by the police
department after Morgenthau
vacated the conviction,
we had enormous trouble getting
videotaping interrogations
passed in this state.
And it didn't happen
until last year.
And I'm going to show you
right now why it happened.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
BARRY SCHECK: Well, if we didn't
have that ad, that by the way,
was filmed by Sarah Burns
and David McMahon, who
made the "Central
Park Five" movie,
we wouldn't have been
able to get this done.
And we just were able to get
this done finally this year.
The videotaping will go into
effect in June of next year,
but the bill was
passed this spring.
So this is an effort
that has to go on
in all the states
in this country that
do not videotape interrogations
from Miranda warnings forward.
And I'm glad to say that the
FBI recently agreed to do that.
But why is the Central Park
Jogger case so important?
It's not just because five
innocent young men wound up
pleading guilty
and wound up giving
confessions that were videotaped
that had all these details.
It has a lot to do
with race in America
and has a lot to
do with our culture
and has a lot to do with
our current president.
So first, Raymond,
let me ask you.
Raymond-- Kevin.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: We look alike.
It's fine.
BARRY SCHECK: Tell us
how you were arrested.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: Good
afternoon, Google.
[APPLAUSE]
Going back to 1989, I see I
have a-- it's young crowd.
So during that time,
I was 14 years old.
1989, I remember it was an
Easter vacation, so excited
to be out for a few days.
I lived across the street from
Central Park, 110th Street,
so I went to the park
quite often to go swimming
and to play basketball and
play football actually.
So I remember that night,
there was a group of guys
forming to go into the park.
I remember a friend
of mine told me,
oh, don't go, like stay
and play basketball.
But I wanted to go anyway.
The only thing I was
guilty of that night
was being a follower, because I
went into the park not thinking
anything was going to happen.
So going into the
park, I remember
a lot of kids forming
together, and I see something.
I see, like, a guy
with a bike going by.
I see him being attacked.
Then, I'm telling myself,
this is not my kind of crowd.
And I had a curfew that night.
I was still 14
years old, so I was
scared of breaking my
curfew more than anything.
So I remember walking out
of the park on Fifth Avenue.
If you're familiar with
Manhattan, Central Park,
it's Fifth Avenue.
So I remember walking back home.
It was kind of late,
and I formed up
with a few guys I didn't know,
and we all was walking upward
Fifth Avenue.
And it was a police van
that swung around the kids.
And growing up during
that time in the '80s,
even if you were innocent,
when you seen police,
you became afraid.
So what I do?
I ran.
Everybody else ran,
so I ran as well.
So I remember turning back
to the wall in Central Park.
So I jumped back into the park,
and I rolled around in mud,
because there's a whole bunch
of grass and things like that.
So this one thing I
remember, it still
stands to this day, which
is a white police officer.
He told me, stay.
Don't run, or I'll shoot.
So I kept running, and all
I remember feeling someone,
like, a physical being over me.
And I remember him tackling me.
At this age I did
not look this size.
I was very slim.
And all I remember is him
taking this police helmet
and hitting me in my face.
And during that time, I remember
blacking out a little bit.
I remember I felt my face
feeling a little swollen.
And if you look back
in the film and you
see when they show the
videotaped confession,
my eye was a little swollen.
I remember asking the police
officer, what are you doing?
I'm innocent.
And he said, didn't I tell you
to freeze, you little animal?
And that always stood out to me.
During that time, I
remember I was really dirty
and I remember handcuffing me.
And they took us out of
the park and put us back
in the police car.
And I was there with
another young kid,
which I did not know.
And in another police car
was, come to found out,
was Raymond Santana, which I
didn't know it at the time,
but they portrayed
that we were gang
or we were some type of cult.
That we was gangs and stuff,
which I didn't know him at all.
And that was the first time I
met Raymond Santana actually.
So from that point, we was drove
to the Central Park precinct.
Like I said, at that time,
the thing I'm most afraid of
is breaking my curfew.
You know, can you imagine?
Because my mother, she
raised us to be responsible.
And I knew that weekend,
it was an Easter vacation,
so I can hang out
a little bit more,
just being a normal
14-year-old teenager.
So I remember going
to the precinct
and being with
other individuals.
Well, I come to find out it was
Yusef Salaam, Raymond Santana.
BARRY SCHECK: And
you didn't know them.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: No.
BARRY SCHECK: That's
what's extraordinary.
And we're not going
to focus right now,
because we don't have the
time, on the methods that
were used to coerce the
confession from Kevin.
The good cop, bad cop
routines and feeding facts
about how the crime
really occurred that,
in theory, only the police
and the real perpetrator
would know.
And look at the movie,
read the literature.
You really need to
read this literature.
But one of the things that
only Kevin can share with us--
take a look at this picture.
See that picture of the
protesters of the Central Park
Five as they're entering court?
And this has always
troubled me enormously,
because I remember all of this.
I was a practicing
criminal defense lawyer.
I was teaching at
Cardozo Law School.
I'd been a public defender.
I knew something
about DNA evidence,
so informally I was
trying to assist
the lawyers in this case, at
least explain what it was.
But all of us involved in
the criminal justice system
were watching this unfold.
And it's just hard to
imagine how it was for you.
Kevin, if you could tell us
what it was like every day
to walk into court
and face trial
with these crowds
outside of the courtroom.
Can you explain for us what
this atmosphere was like?
KEVIN RICHARDSON: During
this time was even '89, 1990.
Almost a full year went by.
And instead of enjoying
regular activity like a kid,
just being outside,
just hanging out,
my everyday life was going
to court, five days a week.
And I was so sheltered
during this time,
and scared to even be outside,
because I didn't think what
people thought of me,
because we was portrayed
so much-- during the '80s,
there was such a media frenzy
during that time.
There was a lot of
racial things going on.
And because of this, it was like
paparazzi around us every day.
They used to come into
actually where I live
and used to interview
people and neighbors
and try to look for us.
We were, like, physically
scared to come outside.
At this time, I was already--
I was 15 years old at the time.
I remember my
family just hovering
over me going to
court, taking a train,
and getting out on Canal Street
and walking to the courthouse
and seeing these signs.
And my mother seeing this
signs about her children
and the other five as well.
And just experiencing
that at 14 years old,
it's hard for anybody
for that matter,
but being so young and naive,
I thought I was in a nightmare
and I actually didn't
wake up from it.
And just going through
this, I thought every day,
what's going to happen to me?
What's going to
happen to my mother?
Because of this, my
mother, she became ill.
She caught a stroke
actually in the courtroom,
and they had to rush her to the
hospital when I was on trial.
It takes me back, just seeing
the sign and just seeing things
like this, because
people didn't--
like, they rushed to judgment.
But they didn't know
that my character.
They didn't know I was
raised by five women.
So it was hard.
BARRY SCHECK: And this picture
shows you just one side.
There was white
people on one side,
people from the black community
and the Latino community
on the other screaming
at each other
as people walk in
to this courthouse.
It was a pretty
terrifying atmosphere.
And one of the
things that happened
is that this man,
Donald Trump, put an ad
in the newspapers,
a full page ad,
calling for the death
penalty to be brought back.
And what we have done is, we
have given you at Google--
and it will be online here--
a copy of this ad.
And what's the
hashtag that we use?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
/bringbackourpolice.
BARRY SCHECK: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: /bringbackourpolice.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: Our police.
BARRY SCHECK: Yeah.
Did you all hear that?
OK, we'll put it in
the tape for the--
And you really need to
read this document, right?
You really need to read it
and take it home with you
and look at it.
Or look at it on your
phone at some point.
But in this ad, the
businessman Donald Trump
went on "Larry King," looks lot
different than he does today.
But he was not being ostracized
for taking this position.
And the kinds of things
he said were, in this ad,
quote, "at what point
did we cross the line
from the fine and noble pursuit
of genuine civil liberties
to the reckless and dangerously
permissive atmosphere which
allows criminals of every age to
beat and rape a helpless woman
and then laugh at her
family's anguish?"
And then he goes
on to criticize,
of all people, Mayor Koch.
Now, Mayor Koch was a real
law and order guy, all right?
But even Mayor Koch during
this period of time,
he's criticizing.
He says, quote,
"Mayor Koch has stated
that hate and rancor should
be removed from our hearts.
I do not think so.
I want to hate these
muggers and murderers.
They should be forced to
suffer and when they kill,
they should be executed
for their crimes.
They must serve as
examples for others,
so that others will think long
and hard before committing
a crime or an act of violence.
"Yes, Mayor Koch, I want
to hate these murderers,
and I always will.
I am not looking to
psychoanalyze or understand
them.
I am looking to punish them.
If the punishment is strong,
the attacks on innocent people
will stop.
I recently watched a newscast
trying to explain the, quote,
'anger in these
young men,' unquote.
I no longer want to
understand their anger.
I want them to
understand our anger.
I want them to be afraid."
And on it goes.
And this is a kind of call
for vigilante justice.
He goes on to tell
the story about how
he was with his
father in a diner,
and people were acting
up in the diner,
and the cops came in and
just threw them out--
self-help.
And it is very reminiscent
of the kinds of things
that I think are
troubling about President
Trump and his campaign.
It is not simply the criticism
of a judge, that he's Mexican,
and therefore he can't be fair.
Did you see in
Suffolk County when
he made that statement
in front of police,
and he said to them, well,
you know, when you put people
in the police car,
you know how you
put your hands over their heads
to make sure they don't get
hurt, well, don't be so nice,
and don't put your hands
over their head.
And essentially was
justifying calling
for, you want to be
rough with these people,
you want to make them scared.
He said this in 1989, 1990.
So Kevin, tell us how you
and your colleagues reacted.
Tell us how your
mother reacted to this.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: OK.
How much time we got?
[LAUGHTER]
BARRY SCHECK: Well, right after
this we'll take your questions.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: Hmm.
Donald Trump.
I can't even say my president.
That's how personal it is
to myself and my family.
When he took this
ad out, my mother
told me a story that it hurt her
and our mothers, our parents,
because it took her back to--
my mother grew up in the
South when there was actually
things like this going on.
There was lynchings and
things of that nature.
And she grew up in
the South, where
she said it was
like a KKK rally,
because he physically
spearheaded a movement
and portrayed hate against us
without knowing who we were.
So I think, during this
case, the public was--
you look at the media
and you look at us--
the public was swayed
to think that we
were these kind of animals.
And I think at the time, if
there was a little bit of logic
used, if you took a step back
and seen, this cannot be true.
But Donald Trump, he
didn't believe that.
And still to this day--
they asked him a question
about it last year
and he said, they're
guilty, they're guilty.
Despite no DNA evidence,
despite anything
you see within the
film or the documents.
It doesn't make sense.
So when he took this ad out, I
was incarcerated at the time.
And I'm hearing about it
when I was incarcerated,
that there are people that's
out there that want us dead.
And that hurt.
And to this day, it still hurts,
because even after my case was
overturned, if there's asking
a question, oh, what do
you feel now, Donald Trump?
If he were to say, well, I
rushed to judgment that time.
I was wrong.
But he's still sticking
to his arrogant ways.
And that's what hurts the most.
Because actually we would love
to even sit down with him,
and look him in the face and
wonder why he said that to us.
But he doesn't want
to speak to us,
and he just believes
what he believes.
So just if he had his way, I
would not be here to this day
talking to you.
If they went back to the days
when people were lynched,
going back to the days of
Emmett Till when he was he
was killed for looking
at a white woman,
because during that time--
right now, these days, everyone
is together for the most part.
But in '89, it was divided.
It was white against black, and
that was a harsh time to see.
And these days, the
youth, we are evolving.
And we need more people to make
it better because of this man.
Because if it was
up to him, he'd
have people that's
really following him.
And they really want to
make America great again.
They really want to take
it back to a slavery stage.
So it's very hard to even
see this to this day.
And it's been 27 years ago.
And that's how much it hurts
deep inside to still see.
Because, yes, my
case was overturned.
Yes, I'm raising my
family, but the five of us,
we have this invisible
scar that nobody sees.
And no money will
cover that, So whenever
I see this, and thinking
about Donald Trump,
is just very harsh.
BARRY SCHECK: And I
urge you to read it.
And it's not-- there
are lots of people
that may believe in capital
punishment for the most
heinous crimes.
And that's not necessarily
a morally bankrupt position
to take.
Reasonable people
can differ about it,
although the death
penalty I don't think you
can take a reasonable position
in favor of the death penalty
as it exists today, in
terms of the race effects,
in terms of our inability
to get it right.
The innocence movement has
certainly demonstrated it.
But what makes the Central
Park Five case so important
to study and to understand--
when you look at this ad
and you look at the things
that Donald Trump
citizen said then,
he wasn't a pariah for
saying these things.
And soon thereafter,
when you look
at the history of criminal
justice in this country,
we had laws that created
mandatory minimum sentences.
We had laws that were passed
in Congress that cut back
on federal habeas corpus.
We had a whole shift.
Even in the years when
crime began going down,
we had all these
measures from which
we are all trying to recover.
And I really do
believe that there's
an alliance between
conservatives and progressives
to bring about criminal
justice reform.
But you will not understand
the roots of resistance
to this unless you look at
the Central Park Five case
and tie it right back to all
the problems we're suffering
and we see vividly in regard to
the controversies arising out
of Charlottesville.
So I'm so thankful,
Kevin, that you're here
today to answer any questions.
I'll certainly do my best.
We ask you to join in the
innocence movement, both here
and across the world.
The people here at
Google and the people
that will be
watching this online,
obviously go to the website
of the Innocence Project
and other organizations.
Give generously.
But more to the point, give
some thought to all the things
that we're trying to do in
science, forensic science,
in cognitive science,
in reforms that we
can bring to this country.
We've been able to
accomplish a lot.
And the good thing about
the innocence movement,
I hope you all realize, that
every time an innocent person
is convicted, as
happened to Kevin
and his colleagues,
the person who's
really committed the crime,
in this case, Matias Reyes,
goes out and can commit
at large another crime.
And so this movement is about
finding out what's wrong,
correcting errors,
and fixing it, which
is very hard in all
kinds of institutions,
and enhancing the capability
of law enforcement
and the court system and all
the stakeholders to make sure
we don't convict
the innocent, but we
do apprehend those who
really did commit the crime.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And so I guess you can all
line up and ask questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
everything, both of you.
I was wondering if you
could speak briefly
about the standards
of evidence on paper
needing to be overwhelming
to convict someone.
To get a conviction
thrown out, do
you just need to establish
a reasonable doubt?
Or are the standards equally
high, or is it even harder
to get something
overturned than it is
to get the original conviction?
BARRY SCHECK: It's very
hard to get something
overturned in most states--
I think, in actually just
about every state right now.
And it wasn't always true.
There are statutes that
say that a state must
have a mechanism whereby
new evidence of innocence
can be brought forward so that
a conviction can be vacated.
In most states, the standard
is a reasonable probability
of a different outcome.
The problem when you talk
about newly discovered evidence
like that is they define newly
discovered evidence as evidence
that couldn't have been
found with the exercise
of due diligence by
the defense lawyer.
So there's plenty of stuff
that lawyers don't find.
We won't go on at any
great length about it,
but Kevin's lawyer was
not up to the task.
And in the middle
of the trial, they
substituted in a new lawyer.
All right.
This case would have been
hard under any circumstances,
but when you go
back and look at it,
there was plenty of information,
particularly the time
line, that raised doubts.
Even some jurors in this
case held out for a while,
because they said,
wow, not withstanding
the publicity and the
terrible way this looks,
we see problems in this case.
So reasonable probability
of a different outcome
is usually the standard.
In some states, it's clear
and convincing evidence
of innocence.
But the problem that we've
had in the United States
is that after a certain
number of years, sometimes
you can't get back into court.
It is very, very, very hard.
And also, if you want to
claim ineffective assistance
of counsel--
and this is something that
is very, very troubling--
the standard for
ineffective assistance
of counsel, Peter
Neufeld and I sometimes
say jokingly and our
colleagues in the movement,
if you put a mirror under
the nose of the lawyer
and it fogs up, that's an
effective lawyer, right?
It's very, very hard to reverse
convictions on that ground.
And one of the reasons
is that they say, well,
the standard is--
what are the likely
errors and omissions
of lawyers in a community
like you're practicing.
And that is defined as too low.
There should be a
national objective
norm of what constitutes
effective assistance
of counsel.
There are jurisdictions all
across this country where
you show up the
first time in court,
there's no lawyers there, right?
People plead guilty
all the time.
We have many, many
great public defenders.
But in general, in terms of
all criminal justice reform,
in my opinion, the least
effective reform movement
now is getting
funds to represent
people charged with crimes.
And it is really the
key, because if we
want to deal with
mass incarceration,
and you want to have a way to
get people who are mentally
ill out of this system, people
who have substance abuse
problems out of the system,
people that have family
violence problems
out of the system
and effectively treated,
to know who should get bail
and who shouldn't, to
have a fair sentencing,
it's got to be individualized.
How can that really
be done unless you
have defense lawyers that
know not just the defendant,
but the whole family?
That knew Kevin was raised
by women, that his mother was
from Richmond, that knew the
whole family context, that
knew everything.
You don't have that
in this country,
because we don't give
money sufficiently to those
who are representing the poor.
And a lot of it has to do
with structural racism,
but we need a Marshall
Plan for indigent defense
in this country.
That's what we need, and we
need to have it working together
with all the stakeholders.
So even if I told you we could
change the legal standard,
we'd still need
lawyers to get it done.
I guess over there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you, Kevin and
Barry, both for being here.
So I wanted to say,
first of all, Kevin,
I'm so sorry for what
you went through.
And I appreciate you being
here to speak for what happened
and to speak and to talk to us.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was here
a couple of years
ago when "Central Park
Five"-- when Sarah
came in and showed that for us.
And I saw the movie again.
And I wanted to ask
you in particular--
I remember in that movie
when she interviewed
the journalist Jim Dwyer.
And he talked about that he
felt badly, that at the time,
he just kind of believed it,
that everybody kind of believed
it, that he didn't think
a little harder about it
and interrogate what the
story that was being told.
And I'm curious to
know, Kevin, when
you hear the news today, things
that are happening today,
is there anything
that you see that you
think that doesn't seem right?
I don't believe that
from my experience.
Is there something, a story
that people are being told today
that isn't quite right, that
people are buying and believing
now, but it's not quite right?
KEVIN RICHARDSON: Yeah.
Well, personally, I guess,
from what I've been through,
when I do see
things on the news,
I take a step back and
actually analyze the situation,
because you can't
rush to judgment fast.
And you have to use a
little logic actually.
And especially now, these
days, with so many things
happening in this
world, whether it's
disasters or things
that's happening,
it's unbelievable to see.
And speaking of like Jim
Dwyer, during that time,
there was many
reporters or people
that maybe felt the same way.
But during that time,
everybody-- not everybody--
there was many that
was on our side,
but there was others that swayed
the other way, because they
probably didn't want to be
that one person that stand out
and stand up for us.
Like, for instance, when
Sarah Burns, when we actually
first met her, myself and
Raymond Santana met Sarah--
when '89 happened,
she was six years old,
so she didn't even
know anything about it.
So she just wanted to find
out more about our case.
And long story short, she
worked for a lawyer of mine,
and she was an intern.
And we met her.
And myself, I was,
when I met her,
I was, like, who is
this young lady that--
she's younger than me.
But she really did her research,
and she was very passionate
about it, because she
wanted to make a difference.
So if we had one person, like
Sarah, that would stand for it,
we'll be better today.
Of course, if we had more people
like the Innocence Project,
we will be better.
And I'm glad that we trying
to make some kind of reform
to make things better like that.
BARRY SCHECK: I
should add something
about good journalism.
And I told Kevin this
story just the other day.
When we were working with
Nancy Ryan and Peter Casolaro
reviewing the case,
it's very hard
to read these
transcripts very quickly.
So we picked up a book by a
journalist named Tim Sullivan
who worked for Court TV.
And he was covering the case.
And I'm reading this book,
and I'm going, oh my god.
He's accurately
reciting everything
that happened in this trial.
It's a very easy read.
He notes all the different
contradictions, makes
it look like a closed
case, explains why
the juror had all these doubts.
So after that seven
month secret period,
right, but before the
announcement was made in court,
I went to see him,
because Court TV had
those offices on Third Avenue
and like 40 something street.
I took him across the street
to this bar called Docks--
I think it's still there--
and sat him down, and I
said, I'm buying your whisky.
I looked at him and I
said, they're all innocent.
And he's looking at me, and
he just couldn't believe it.
And of course, eventually he
did, and he understood it.
But what was great about it,
is you could go back and find
a document where somebody
just looking objectively
at the evidence
contemporaneously
was able to highlight
all the problems.
Because if you just watch
the news, you'd think this
was an open and shut case.
Oh my god, they've
got these confessions.
Now, of course, by the time
they turn on the cameras,
people have been
told what to say,
taken to the scene of the
crime, all kinds of things.
And of course, they
showed no remorse.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you both for being here.
My sister-in-law works
for the Innocence Project,
and she's in the process
of applying to law school,
so she can continue her passion.
BARRY SCHECK: Good.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is sort of similar,
but you shared
this advertisement,
and there was a headline that
you shared of a newspaper.
And so I was just curious your
perspective on 30 years later,
the media landscape has changed.
And in theory, we are
able to see, get access
to more information.
Sometimes people are even
posting videos of things
that they've observed
online, that they've seen
from the scene of the crime.
And do you think
that helps or hurts?
And are things getting
better or worse?
What is the role of
the media companies
in sort of helping to
mitigate some of these issues
that you guys brought up?
If you have a perspective,
I'd love to hear it.
KEVIN RICHARDSON: Well,
I think it helps now,
because people are more aware.
And thank god for
internet and media,
because people really
want to know the truth.
And situation that's happening
now, far as police brutality,
you see it.
People are filming it.
It's online.
You Google it, you check it out.
And so I think it helps
out, because people just
want to be--
want to know for
themselves what happened.
As far as now
videotape is being--
you could see it,
the footage now.
Because in my case,
you didn't see
anything that was happening
behind closed doors.
So now you see that, now
you can see what's going on.
And maybe it'll be
a little change.
So I think it helps actually.
BARRY SCHECK: Well,
it's complicated,
as you know, here with Google.
As Kevin said, there is
so much more information
out that you can
get quickly, right?
You can get transcripts.
You can go online
and look at decisions
and look up people and look
at their Facebook pages
and the social media and get
some much more information
than you ever could before.
And there are increasingly
websites that,
on criminal justice
issues, are terrific,
like the Marshall Project.
I highly recommend that.
Those of us in the criminal
justice reform movement,
we get up in the morning, we
look at the Marshall Project.
But what I want to
commend to your attention
about the Marshall
Project is the person
who really started it
is Bill Keller, who
was an editor of
"The New York Times."
And all the people that are
involved in the Marshall
Project and other journalists
that they bring in
to write articles,
they care about facts.
They care about what's truthful.
They'll be politically
incorrect when
it comes to looking at
solutions to the problems.
I think it's great that there
are all kinds of other websites
that can do this and
investigative teams
like the people at ProPublica.
It's a heyday now
for publications,
like "The Atlantic" have
been terrific and of course,
"The New Yorker"
and others that will
do deep dives and
investigative reports.
But what's so important
now is that we have
to stop being so tribalized.
You really have to search
the web and look for facts.
And I'm hopeful-- we
don't have it now,
but I'm hopeful that
what will happen
is that we will begin to
get authoritative voices,
whether they're on the left
or the right or anywhere,
where you will have some
assurance that what I'm seeing
online here so quickly has
actually been fact checked,
that responsible people
are doing the research,
so we'll get some confidence
in the truth of what's
being reported.
These democratic
rights that we have--
the presumption of innocence,
trial by jury, proof
beyond a reasonable doubt--
you think these
things are just going
to be here forever and work.
Wake up.
Unless you fight
for them, people
will say, well, be scared.
Let's go punish them.
I didn't make this up.
Go look at that ad
that President Trump,
when he was a citizen, raised.
I mean, this is what
he really believed,
and he wasn't run out of
town because he said it.
And I wish he would really
give it more thought.
Nobody should be
considered hopeless
in this kind of enterprise,
but if you want a democracy,
you're going to have
to fight for it.
If you want a fair
criminal justice system,
you're going to have
to fight for it,
because it is really imperiled
and under attack in many ways
today.
On the other hand, I'm
extremely optimistic myself
that people such as yourselves
will look at this history,
learn the lessons, bring to
bear real science, real science,
in looking at how this system
can work and will protect
the innocent and try our
very best to convict only
those who committed the crimes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much
for having this event
and speaking here.
I have a kind of
obvious question,
which I can appreciate
as probably very
difficult to answer.
But is there any
research done to estimate
the number of people
that are currently
incarcerated that are innocent?
How many are there?
BARRY SCHECK: Yeah.
That's a great question,
and people ask all the time,
how many innocent
people are in jail?
And the answer to that is,
well, if I knew, I'd tell you.
We have huge backlogs at the
Innocence Project and innocence
organizations across the
country of people claiming
to be innocent that we're trying
to help all of our colleagues
and look at.
A very good study
was done by Sam gross
from the University
of Michigan Law School
and I think Barbara O'Brien
from Michigan State that
was published in the "National
Academy of Science Journal."
Because in order to get a
handle on this question,
you have to compare
apples to apples.
And I can tell
from your question
that you understand the
difficulties of this.
And we do have a class of
cases that we can look at.
And that is capital
cases, because we
have more data on those.
We have more
transcripts, more of them
gone through the court system.
And then frankly, even though
capital representation isn't
as good over the years
as it should have been,
it is better ordinarily--
or more resources
are devoted to it,
let's put it that way--
than the average case.
And what they've
been able to estimate
is that the error
rate is at least 4%.
And they were comparing capital
cases over a period of time,
where they could look at
real evidence of innocence,
compared to other cases.
AUDIENCE: That's so high.
BARRY SCHECK: What?
AUDIENCE: That's
really, really high.
BARRY SCHECK: Well,
that is absolutely--
you're quite correct in
say-- the questioner said
that's so high.
And of course, it's high when
you consider that we have,
what, something like that
more than two million people
incarcerated in
the United States,
more per capita than
just about anywhere.
And then you look at a
lot of these place states,
like Louisiana,
which has the highest
per capita incarceration
plate of any jurisdiction
on the planet.
And that's one reason we get
all these innocent people out
in Louisiana.
There's plenty of them there.
So the rate is very high.
There's other data that is
very suggestive about this.
When we first began doing
DNA testing, starting in 1989
and moving forward,
and the FBI was
one of the few
public agencies that
would do it for state and
local law enforcement for free,
they were finding
consistently when they
had a suspect in a case, right?
Which in theory meant that
there was some probable cause
or reasonable basis for picking
somebody up, arresting them,
charging them, and then
they would move forward
with the DNA testing--
that one third of the
time, the primary suspect
was excluded by the DNA testing.
So that is very, very
suggestive that the rate
of innocent people
being convicted
is much higher than
any of us ever thought.
And that is the truth.
I think that the one thing
you'll find from our colleagues
in the prosecution, we
get a lot of support
from the International
Association
of Chiefs of Police,
from policing people
all across the country, because
police officers, when they
go into it, they
didn't get into it
and risking their
lives because they want
to lock up the wrong person.
They want to lock up the right
person and protect the public.
| we need to make
that job easier.
We need to bring more
science to bear on this.
We need to change
those institutions,
so we can get better at it.
It's a very difficult
and imperfect enterprise.
And we have to constantly
be improving the system.
But there is no doubt-- that's
what DNA and the innocence
movement proved, I think, to
everybody's satisfaction among
stakeholders in the
criminal court system--
that there are far more innocent
people than anybody ever,
ever, ever suspected.
And we are still at the
beginning of this process.
I mean, when we started
this 25 years ago,
this is our 25th anniversary
of the Innocence Project.
And you'll see "Time Magazine"
did a whole issue that you
can find on this
on the newsstands
right now, because it is
an important historical
and cultural and
political development
to see an innocence movement.
Everybody thought that
as more DNA testing
was done at the
beginning of the case,
right, that we'd all
go out of business.
Well, the answer is, we have
more exonerations, which
look at the National Registry
numbers, than ever before.
And the DNA has
remained constant
in terms of the
number of old cases.
And even some new ones, where
the DNA wasn't done right,
we've been able to
exonerate people.
But we now know more
about how innocent people
get convicted and get better at
trying to correct these errors.
So that's a very--
you're right it's a
complicated question.
If you put a gun to my head and
said, what's the error rate,
I'll go with the article in
"The National Academy of Science
journal," at least 4%.
AUDIENCE: So that's
like 100,000 people.
BARRY SCHECK: Oh,
it's more than that.
And in truth, I mean, guessing.
But we don't like to guess.
We like to bring
all the data that we
can to bear on the problem.
So I think that's it.
And we thank you
very, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And hope for your support.
Anyone in the innocence
movement, go online--
innocenceproject.org,
Innocent Network,
any innocence organization in
your jurisdiction, and help us.